well tonight we are remembering a life
loss too soon the little boy found two
weeks ago in mountain springs is being
remembered right now in san jose and
that is where
we now go for a live report yeah it'll
happen there in about
actually 10 minutes but first a
seven-year-old liam husted as you
probably know remained
nameless as police worked for a couple
of weeks to identify him
without the help of social media it
could have taken even longer to find out
who he was
victoria saha spoke with the national
center for missing and exploited
children
and they actually helped come up with
that digitally enhanced picture which
really eventually helped quite a bit
victoria
yes denise the forensic imaging
supervisor tells me the team at the
national center for missing and
exploited
children worked long hours to get
pictures of liam houston out there and
make sure they look as realistic
as possible ever since the discovery of
the boy nearly two weeks ago it's gotten
a lot of attention
colin mcnally with the national center
for missing and exploited children
worked
countless hours with law enforcement and
the coroner to create these images
ultimately helping crack the case those
images were shared across
social media platforms eventually a
friend of liam's mom in san jose came
across it
and called police this is a highlight
for me and my time at neckmak and it
really does highlight the power of
social media
seeing how many people engaged on this
case you know highlighting
the success on this case on other social
media platforms
you know it's it's really great to
highlight this specific case but it
really does also
highlight the other cases that are out
there other children that deserve to
have their names back
earlier this week police released actual
pictures of liam and his mom 35-year-old
samantha marino rodriguez was arrested
in denver in connection with his death
as we mentioned a vigil for liam is
getting underway at this hour in san
jose we will bring you a live report
from there
in just about five minutes reporting
live from the newsroom victoria saha 8
news now victoria thanks for that report